สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไร
คะวันนี้วันจันทร์
ค่ะวัน
[เพลง]
นี้วันนี้วันจันทร์นะคะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่
23 เดือนอะไรคะเดือนตุ
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วันอาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
22 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพคศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
24 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
ตุลาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
20  23 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้
เวลา 14 นอื 14 นกี่
นาที
นค่ะ
1429 นก็เป็นตอนกลางวันเกลางวันนะคะแล้ว
ก็ 14:00 นแล้วครูฟ้ากินข้าวกี่ครั้งแล้ว
คะวัน
นี้ครูฟ้ากินข้าวไป 5 ครั้งแล้วค่ะโ
เดี๋ยวเดี๋ยวๆๆๆๆวันนี้เนี่ยวันวันจันทร์
ใช่มยครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นนอนกี่โมงคะครูฟ้า
ตื่น
นอนแป๊บนึงนะคะพอเลือกสีก่อนได้ได้ค่ะ
เดี๋ยวครูหญิงเอา 1429 ออกมาไว้ตรงนี้นะ
เอา
อ่า
ะหนเรียน
งง
ไม่ต้องนักเรียนงงครูหญิงก็งงค่ะอันนี้
เพิ่ง 14:00 แล้วคุณตื่นนอน PM ได้ยังไง
โอเค 8 นใช่มตั้งแต่ 800 นเนี่ยจนมาถึง
14:00 นเนี่ย 9:00 น 10:00 น 1100 น 12
น 13:00 น 14:00 น 6
ชมเนาะ 6 ชมมเนี่ยนะคะตั้งแต่ครูฟ้าตื่น
นอน 8:00 นจนถึง
14 นครูฟ้าเนี่ยกินข้าวกี่ครั้ง
แล้วกิน
ข้าว 3 ครั้งได้
ม 3 ครั้งแล้วหรอเ้าก็กินตลอดนะ
คะครูฟ้ากินหิวก็กินหิวก็กินหิวก็กินหรอ
ใช่ใช่ค่ะนักเรียน
เอ่อครั้งแรกเนี่ยก็ขนมปังใช่มย
ค่ะ
อุ้ยครูหญิงก็ไปรบของครูฟ้านะ
คะขนมปังกับนมไงขนมปังก็อ่าอันนี้ก็คือ
ตื่นนอนมาครูฟ้าก็กินเลยเหรอคะขนมปังแล้ว
ก็นมใช่ขนมปัง 3 แผ่นนะคะแล้วก็นมอือะไร
คะผู้หญิง
แต่ฟ้ากินสีนะคะออโอเควันนี้น้อยแล้วใช่
มยคะใช่ค่ะพอกินขนมปังเสร็จนะคะก็อาจจะรอ
สัก 10 นครึ่ง 2 ช่วโมงครึ่งรอ 2 ชมง
ครึ่ง
ใช่กินอะไรอีกคะ
กินพก็กินนี่นะคะกินอะไรคะซีเรียลนะคะกิน
ซีเรียล
ออซีเรียลนะคะรู้แล้วนักเรียนบอกรู้แล้ว
เห็นเห็นแล้วอุ้ยแป๊บนึงใช่อันนี้คือกิน
ครั้งที่ 2 ซีเรียลแล้วกินซีเรียลไป 3
ชามนะคะโจำได้ว่า 3 ชามชาม
เ 3  3 ครูฟ้า 2  2 ช่วโมงที่แล้วคุณ
เพิ่งกินขนมปัง 3 แผ่นดื่มนมซีเรียลอีก 3
ช้าแล้วยังมีครั้งที่ 3 อีกนะคะใน 6
ช่วโมง
เนี่ยครั้งที่ 3 กินอะไรครั้งที่ 3 กิน
เอ่อผัดซีอิ๊วค่ะโห No อุ๊ยๆๆอาหารไทย
อาหาร
ไทยอ่ะเดี๋ยวผูหญิงเสิร์ชให้นะน่าจะมีนะ
ตรง
เยซให้ครูฟ้าวาดไปเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงก็หาให้
ผัดซี
อิ๊วนักเรียนงงว่าคืออะไรนี่นี่ใช่มมคะัว
ชอบกินผัซีอิวมาก
นะคือมันก็ยังทำไม่ได้เพราะไงครูฟ้าก็จะ
ตาม
มา
สิ่งที่ครูฟ้าวาดไว้จะตามมานี่ๆๆนักเรียน
เอ้านี่ผัดซีอิ๊วนะคะผัดซีอิ๊วอ่ากินผัด
ซีอิ๊วกี่ชามคะกี่จาน 1 ค่ะเพราะมันเยอะ
แล้ว 1 จานสบายใจครูฟ้าทำไมครูฟ้ากินเยอะ
มากอ้าวครูฟ้าไม่กลัวอ้วนเหรอ
คะไม่กลัว
ทำไมอ่ะครูหญิงเนี่ยกัวทำไมครูหญิงเนี่ย
ตื่น 6 นเอ่อไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่ใช่ 6:00 นค่ะ
โกหกู้หญิงเนี่ยตื่น 800 นเหมือนครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เนี่ย 00 นู่หญิงเนี่ยกิน 1 ครั้ง
เท่า
นั้นผู้หญิงผู้หญิงกิน 1 ครั้งเองหรอใช่
แล้วก็ก็ผู้หญิงเนี่ยกิน
แอปเปิ้ล
แอปเปิ้ลแล้วก็
โยเกิร์ตอันนี้เป็นโยเกิร์ตนะนักเรียน
โยเกิร์ตแล้วก็แอปเปิ้ลกินแอปเปิ้ลกับ
โยเกิร์ตเท่านั้นครู้หญิงกินเยอะๆไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ครูฟ้าตอนนี้ครูหญิงคิดๆๆลดน้ำหนัก
อยู่แอปเปิ้ลและน้ำเหรอไม่โยกโไม่ใช่อ๋อย
เกผู้หญิงคะครูหญิงกินน้อยมากนะคะเอ้าครู
หญิงอ่านมาครูหญิงเนี่ยเปิดในนี่ค่ะครู
ฟ้าอะไรคะเนี่ย
กากบาทถูกนะคะอันนี้ผิดนะคะอันนี้ถูกไม่
ใช่ไม่ใช่
แอปพลิเคชันแอปพลิเคชัน x ค่ะครู
ฟ้า Twitter
Twitter นั่นแหละก็ครูหญิงเนี่ยเห็นใช่
มั้ยมีโทรศัพท์แล้วก็ดูใน Twitter เา้า
บอกว่าถ้าเราคิดคิดอยากลดน้ำหนักเพราะว่า
ครูหญิงคิดโอ้ตอนนี้ใช่มยอืครูหญิงเนี่ย
มีกางเกงนะคะมีกางเกงเนี่ยกางเกงูหญิง
เนี่ยโอ้
เอวเอาเอวหรือเอาไซสดีเอาไซส์แล้วกันเนาะ
กางเกงเนี่ยครูหญิงเมื่อก่อนครูหญิงซื้อ
เนี่ยไซส์ XL ใช่ม XL เนี่ยแล้วครูหญิงก็
ใส่กางเกงโอเคสบายบไม่ได้แบบแน่น 100%
อันนี้กางเกงเนี่ยซื้อ 2  0  2  2 ใช่
มั้ยคะแต่ตอนนี้เดือน
ตุลาคม 2  0  2  3 เนี่ยเวลาครูหญิงใส่
กางเกงไซส์ XL ตัวนี้รู้สึกแบบทำไมกางเกง
มัน
เล็กมันไม่โอเคแล้วครูฟ้าครูหญิงต้อง
เปลี่ยนจาก XL เป็นอะไร xxl แล้ว
หรอแต่ไทยไซสนะคะนักเรียนไทยไซสนะบอกไว้
ก่อนไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ Universal ไเออไใช่ค่ะ
ประเทศไทยเนี่ย XL เนี่ยนะคะมันไม้ใหญ่นะ
คะนักเรียนน่าจะประมาณ L  29 มั้ย XL  XL
เนี่ย L  29 อออซึ่งนักเรียนอาจจะเป็น M
หรือ L ใช่มยคะตก็เนี่ยคุหญิงก็เลยคิด
อุ้ยไม่ได้แล้ว 1 ปีครูหญิงเนี่ยเปลี่ยน
ไซส์กางเกงครูหญิงก็เลยคิดลดน้ำหนักอยาก
หอมถึงถามครูฟ้าไงว่าครูฟ้าทำไมกินเยอะ
มากแล้วก็อ่านไงเล่นอินเทอร์เน็ต
โซเชียลมีเดียแล้วเขาก็บอกว่าถ้าเราคิดพก
อันนี้เป็นตัวเราอ่ะเนาะนักเรียนครูหญิง
ก็ไม่ได้อยากผอมขนาดนั้นนะคะอันนี้เป็น
ครูหญิงจมูกโด่ง
จังนี้แล้วเราเราก็มีพุงตรงนี้ไงเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยนักเรียนเนี่ยครูฟ้าเนี่ยเาไม่มี
นะคะครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่มีตรงนี้ไงเมีพุงใช่
มั้ยเพราะว่าผู้หญิงเนี่ยกินแล้วก็นั่ง
สอนภาษาไทยสอนภาษาไทยอ่ะใช่มพอกินเสร็จ
แล้วก็มาเนี่ยครูหญิงก็มี
เก้าอี้แล้วครูหญิงก็นั่งนั่ง 1 วันเนี่ย
6 ชมงโหคหญิเดินนิดหน่อยอย่างเงี้ยปาก
เนี่ยพูดพูดูดใช่มั้ยแต่ตัวเนี่ยนั่งก็
เลยคิดว่าอุ๊ยพุงเนี่ยนะคะพุงตรงนี้มันก็
ใหญ่ขึ้นใหญ่ขึ้นเห็นมั้ยกางเกง XL ก็เลย
ต้องเปลี่ยนไซส์ xxl ก็คิดิดคอยากลดน้ำ
หนักลดน้ำหนักอทำยังไงอือสมมุติว่าผู้
หญิงหนัก
กกอืเนี่ยโอ้ไม่โอเคอยากลดใช่มั้ยคะให้
เหลือประมาณ
55 กิโกรัมเลดน้ำหนักอยากลดพุงหน้าท้อง
ด้วยอืก็เจอเา้าบอกว่าให้กิน
แอปเปิ้ล
แอปเปิ้ลกับโยเกิร์ตไม่ต้องแอปเปิ้ลก็ได้
ให้กินโยเกิร์ตทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันผู้หญิง
คะกิน
โยเกิร์ต
อืกินโยเกิร์ตทุกวันนี่คือกินโยเกิร์ต 3
มื้อเลยเหรอคะใช่จริงๆครู
ฟ้าแต่ว่าตอนมันหิวนะเดี๋ยวฟังก่อนครู
หญิงตอนนี้เนี่ยกินข้าว 1 วัน 2 มื้อเท่า
นั้นก็คือมื้อที่ 1 อมื้อเช้าเนี่ยครู
หญิงกินประมาณ 99:00 นแล้วก็มื้อที่ 2
เนี่ยประมาณ 16 นอือันนี้ต่อ 1 วันเพราะ
ว่าครูหญิงคิดลดน้ำหนักไงก็เลยคิดว่าเอ๊
เราเนี่ยเดินนิดหน่อยเห็นมั้ยครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ทุกวันทุกวันเนี่ย
บ้านโรง
เรียน
บ้านออฟฟิใช่มยร้านอาหารครูฟ้าเนี่ยเดินๆ
ๆๆๆๆๆๆดๆมากๆแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ยนิดหน่อยีก็
เลยคิดโอเคกินน้อย
ลงจากเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนเนี่ยกิน 1
กิน 3 ครั้งใช่มั้ยคะกิน 3 มื้อ
มกิน 3 ตอนนี้ก็เหลือ 2 อย่างเงี้ยค่ะอ่า
แล้วก็กิน
โยเกิร์ต 2 มื้อถ้าเราหิวแล้วเรากิน
โยเกิร์ตแบบ
ว่าเพราะว่ากินโยเกิร์ตใช่มยคะเรากิน
โยเกิร์ต 10 ถ้วยได้มั้ยคะถ้าเราหิวเพมัน
หิวไงนักเรียนโยเกิร์ตมันนิดหน่อยนะคะผู้
หญิงก็เลยใส่แอปเปิ้ลไงใส่แอปเปิ้ลเอ้าก็
ผู้หญิงไม่รู้รู้ไงครูฟ้าครูหญิงรู้แบบ
ว่าอ๋อถ้าครูหญิงคิดิดๆอยากลดน้ำหนักก็
กินน้อยลงแล้วก็อ่านเจอเขาบอกให้กิน
โยเกิร์ตก็กินโยเกิร์ตเพราะว่าคิดว่ามัน
จะลดน้ำหนักได้ครูหญิงเนี่ยจะได้ผอมไงนัก
เรียนก็อาจจะคิดว่าทำไมครูหญิงไม่ออก
กำลังกายเนาะอืเอ้ามันก็ต้องกินด้วยนะคะ
มันต้องออกอกำลังกายแล้วก็กินให้ถูกด้วย
ใช่เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะก็คิดว่าใน 7
วันใช่มยตอนนี้นะตอนนี้นะคะใน 7 วันเนี่ย
ก็ประมาณ 3  2-3 วันแล้วกันไม่ใช่ถึง 3
วันหรอก
2-3
วันอืครูหญิงเนี่ยก็จะไปฟิตเนสใช่มย
คอนโดมิเนียมครูหญิงเนี่ยมีฟิตเนสนะคะ
แล้วมันจะมีอันนี้
อย่างี้
ป่ะ
อืแล้วก็มีหน้าจอแล้วก็พี่เล่น
น้ำนั่นน่ะสิวาดไม่เหมือนเลยนะเนี่ยสกิ
วิ่งลู่วิ่งไงตหะลูวิ่งเหมือเออๆๆให้กูก็
ไม่รู้นะแต่ว่ามันมันก็อย่างงี้นะใช่ๆๆๆ
เก่งมากค่ะครูฟ้านี่ๆแล้วก็ครูหญิงก็อยู่
ที่นี่ใช่มยนักเรียนใช่ค่ะ
อืแล้วก็เวลาประมาณสัก 15 นเนี่ย 15 นครู
หญิงก็จะเปลี่ยนเสื้อเปลี่ยนใส่กางเกงขา
สั้นใช่่มยกางเกงอแล้วก็ลงไปข้างล่างแล้ว
ก็ไปวิ่งนะคะวิ่งที่ลู่วิ่งเนี่ย
ประมาณอาจจะไม่ได้วิ่งนะนักเรียนเดินเดิน
เดบนลวิ่งเนี่ย
20 ถึง 30
นาที
อื 30 นาทีก็อาจจะแบบสมมุติวัน
อังคารวัน
พฤหัสบดีแล้วก็วันอาทิตย์อย่างเงี้ยค่ะก็
3 วันหรือว่าบางอาทิตย์ก็วันอังคารไป
วิ่งวันพฤหัสบดีไปวิ่งวันอาทิตย์เอาดี
กว่าก็อย่างงี้ไงคิดโอเคออกกำลังกายด้วย
กินน้อยลงด้วยว่าอยากลดน้ำหนักไงออืก็
โอเคนะอันนี้โอเคนะคะเพราะว่าลดน้ำหนัก
เนี่ยต้องออกกำลังกายใช่มยอืซึ่งกินด้วย
นะคะแต่บางคนก็กินนิดหน่อยเพื่อลดน้ำหนัก
ก็โอเคไงบางคนไม่้ออกกำลังกายใช่ครูหญิง
คิดว่าผู้หญิงแบบแบบครูหญิงอย่างเงี้ยแบบ
ออกกำลังกายไปวิ่ง
เออไม่เอาก็คิดกินน้อยลงใช่มั้ยคะกินอ
หน่อยจ้ะหรือว่าบางคนบางทีเราก็ไม่กินแบบ
อันนี้ผัดซีอิ๊วก็ไม่ได้นะคะทำไมคะอร่อย
นะคะผัดสอิวว่าชอบมากใชหรผู้หญิงก็ผู้
หญิงเนี่ยเป็นคนที่ชอบ
ชอบเนี่ยค่ะนักเรียนผักเนี่ยโอเคนะกินได้
หมูธรรมดาเนี่ยค่ะนักเรียนคาร์โบไฮเดรต
เนี่ยนะคะพิซซ่าสปาเกตตี้เนี่ยครูหญิง
เนี่ยชอบมากหรือว่าพวกขนม
ปังอะไรที่เป็นแบบคาร์โบไฮเดรตแบบเนี้ย
ชอบมากๆพอครูหญิงคิดจะลดน้ำหนักครูหญิงก็
ต้องแบบกินน้อยลง
อืกินน้อยลงลงด้วยใช่ค่ะหรือว่าบางคนใช่
มั้ยคะที่แบบว่าโอ้โหเนี่ยชอบกิน
ขนมชอบมากทุกอย่างในนี้นะฮโดนัทเนี่ยคะ
เทงไอศครีมชานมไข่มุกโอเนี่ยชานมไข่มุก
เนี่ยนะคะเวลาประเทศไทยเนี่ยเราร้อนใช่
ไหมประเทศของเราเนี่ยมันร้อนมากๆนะคะแบบ
33 องศาเซซร้อนเราคนไทยเนี่ยชอบดื่มชานม
ไข่มุกชานมไข่มุกเนี่ยผู้หญิงก็เคยชอบนะ
เมื่อก่อนน่ะแบบดื่มๆืๆืแต่ไม่ทุกวันผู้
หญิงอาจจะประมาณ 4
วัน 4 วันต่ออาทิตย์นะคะเอ่อดื่มซึ่งพอ
ดื่มดื่มากๆรู้สึกแบบเอ๊ะทำไมกางเกง
เปลี่ยนไซส์ซืเเปลี่ยนไซส์อะไรอย่างเงี้ย
มันอ้วนนะยิ่งคหญิงเนี่ยค่ะภูฟ้าเนี่ย
อายุน้อยกว่า 30 ใช่มย 30 เนี่ยครูฟ้า
เนี่ยอายุน้อยกว่า 30 ครูหญิงเนี่ยอายุ
มากกว่า
30 กินก็จะอ้วนเร็วๆไงผู้หญิงก็จะแบบไม่
ไม่เอาไม่ดื่มน้ำที่มันหวานๆแบบชานมไข่
มุกโค้กครูฟ้ามีโค้กใช่มย
ใช่ค่ะนี่ค่ะครูฟ้ามีโค้กค่ะอ่าโค้กเนี่ย
เป็นเครื่องดื่มที่เป็นน้ำหวานๆเนี่ยู้
หญิงก็คิดไม่ดื่มดื่มน้ำเปล่าอันนี้คือ
น้ำนะน้ำนะคะหรือว่ากาแฟผู้หญิงก็ดื่ม
อเมริกาโน่กาแฟ 100%  American  Black
กาแฟสีดำไม่อร่อยเลยไม่ต้องเพื่อหอมค่ะลด
น้ำหนักไงลาเต้อย่างเงี้ยก็ไม่ได้มีนมอือ
อ
โธ่ครูหญิงไม่อร่อยเลยนะคะอาหารลดน้ำหนัก
เลยใช่นั่นแหละพอเห็นครูฟ้าบอกว่าวันนี้
ครูฟ้ากิน 3 มื้อแล้วครูหญิงก็แบบอือครู
หญิงก็คิดอยากกินเหมือนครูฟ้าแต่ครูหญิง
ไม่ชอบโดนัทไม่ชอบคัพเค้กนะแต่ผู้หญิงชอบ
ไอศกรีมมากๆผู้หญิงเนี่ยมีไอศกรีมเมื่อ
ก่อนนะเป็นเป็นคอสเหรออืคอสอ่ะค่ะอ่า 4 ค
ครู
ฟ้าคือมันซื้อ 2 รี 2 ก็เลยเป็น 4  qu
แต่เป็นมินินะมินิคสแค่นี้แค่นี้ิคอแต่
เวลาครูหญิงอยากกินูหญิงหยิบมา 1 มินิค
แล้วก็กินๆๆๆหมดอ่ะอืนั่นไงไม่ไดู้หญิงก็
ต้องแบบอืเพราะว่าครูหญิงคิดอยากลดน้ำ
หนักไงคูหญิงออกกำลังกายแต่กินไอศครีมกิน
เค้กกินชานมไข่มุกมันก็ยังไม่ผอมใช่มยคะ
ผู้หญิงก็เลยคิดอผู้หญิงต้องดูการกินต้อง
กินดีๆใช่มเวลาเราคิดอยากลดน้ำ
หนักกินน้อย enjoy  eating ไม่ได้แล้วน่ะ
ูหญิงอืูหญิงต้องกินให้มันโอเคนะคะต้อง
กินผลมไม้อย่างแอปเปิ้ลกล้วยอย่างเงี้ย
สตรอเบอร์รี่ก็โอเคใช่มยผลไม้นะคะ
กีวี่อ้าเออใช่ๆๆกินผลไม้อะไรก็ได้เนาะ
ที่ไม่ใช่ทุเรียนใช่มั้ยคะทุเรียนอร่อยนะ
คะทุเรียนอ้วนไงนี่ๆผลไม้พวกนี้เนาะอุ๊ย
เลมอนนี่องุ่นอย่างงี้ใช่มองุ่นไม่ค่อย
โอเคเหรอหวานองุ่นหวานใช่เออก็ถ้าครูหญิง
คิดอยากลดน้ำหนักเนาะก็ต้องกินดีๆแล้วก็
ออกกำลังกายด้วยใช่ยคะเนี่ยแหละค่ะตอนนี้
ก็เลยครูหญิงกำลังลดน้ำหนักอยู่นะคะนัก
เรียนนักเรียนก็ดูแล้วกันว่าเวลาดู
วีีดีโอแล้วหน้าครูหญิงเนี่ยเล็กลงมยนะคะ
ใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าวดีโอนี้หมดเวลาแล้วนะคะ
เดี๋ยวเราเจอกันใหม่วีีดีโอหน้านะคะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ